What are the acceptable forms of B12 for cancer patients?
Remember, we'll try to stay away from methylated supplements,
unless you have elevated homocysteine.
So if you do not have elevated homocysteine,
but you have cancer, what is it acceptable for it would be 12?
You want to take hydroxychombolamine
as typically the one that we use.
But, uh,
professional health products has a pro-hydroxychombolamine.
Seeking health has a hydroxychombolamine.
You can also use a denticel-chombolamine.
Seeking health has a denticel-slash-hydroxy,
so it's 50-50 blend.
I'm not sure that that's necessary.
Typically, people take hydroxychombolamine.